do you want sound legal advice but
aren't near a billboard well there's
only one place to turn fox news is
justice with judge Jeanine now this show
is hosted by Jeanine Pirro a former
prosecutor judge and the last person you
want to spill red wine on no namby-pamby
bleeding-heart left-wing socialist
political whore and it's possible
martians were in that room
peeing on the prostitutes - you lost he
won Karma's a bitch sorry mom say a
judge Janine like they say a little goes
all the way her shows 60 minutes of
legal wisdom smothered in a generous
layer of Rage it's can't miss but
sometimes I miss it it airs on Saturdays
which is when my one-man neighborhood
watch goes on Patrol started it after
the regular neighborhood watch kicked me
out over the shark blood incident bunch
of pussies now luckily we have citizen
lawyer Laura gray to keep us updated on
all things Janine Thank You Jordan judge
Jeanine is an American institution
she's like baseball if the entire game
was just screaming at the umpire to
arrest Hillary Clinton this week she
went all in on former FBI director James
Comey and his softcore fantasy novel
about Donald Trump listen this heat Jim
it's so obvious you're fired and you're
mad you're a liar and you're a leaker
your pompous your egotistical your
condescending your cocky
your awkwardly tall you're a bad tipper
you think the wire season five was
better than season four you're a monster
James call me and judge Jeanine gets
that yes yes now that's that's the sound
of reasonable discourse turned all the
way up to 12 oh yeah it's the future of
news Jordan and it makes me feel
powerful like when I go to the mall food
court to watch teenage couples fight
now judge to me it's an intellectual
bulldog she bites down on an idea and
doesn't let go until she shot with a
blow dart which coincidentally is how
her producer ends her show every way but
that doesn't mean she's not
sophisticated see if you can pick up on
some of the elevated language she used
this weekend
Jim you hoisted yourself on your own
petard don't you love it when arrogant
egomaniacs are hoisted on their own
petard FBI director James Comey and
deputy director Andrew McCabe now know
the pain of those petard did you catch
it it's hard now I know what you're all
thinking
I know exactly what petard means me too
it's a French grenade from the 16th
century you know back when the French
military did stuff what she means here
is that Comey is accidentally
undermining himself getting blown apart
by his own bomb something Janine would
never do because she's too busy going
for the jugular or as I call them neck
balls Jim you've done more damage to the
FBI is an institution than J Edgar
Hoover the only difference between you
and J edgar is that he wore dresses and
even if you wanted to you probably
couldn't get one to fit you at 6 feet 8
inches yeah good luck shopping at
tablet's petite you too tall weirdo
judge Jeanine is a fighter she knows you
sting like a butterfly and also sting
like a beef and she's been covering
Comey for years with total consistency
like here's how she talked about lying
leaking crusty Comey back in December
2015 there is a hero in Washington his
name Jim Comey he is not only brilliant
he is honest hardworking and he comes
from a long line of law enforcement
politics plays no role in his decisions
he's in it for all the right reasons
wait Laura I got it I got it
no no I gotta say I've gotta say that
actually that seems pretty inconsistent
any ideas the intensity is the same an
intensity it's an only thing that
matters
judge toninho's petards because she is
one she explodes with equal destruction
in every direction every Saturday night
she's hoisting America and nothing can
stop her from doing what she feels which
in this case is saying hey Comey you
look like in a ball gown you
stretched out choirboy yeah considered a
hoisted Laura Gray everyone
[Music]